none of the humanitarian crisis in
Puerto Rico food water and relief
supplies are trickling in to Puerto Rico
ten days after Hurricane Maria crashed
ashore as a category 4 storm crippling
the island nearly 17-hundred Defense
Department personnel are on the island
working to restore power and distribute
aid another 3,000 are expected in the
next few days FEMA says it has
distributed more than 2 million meals
around Puerto Rico and
telecommunications are now restored to
about 30% of the island on Friday
President Trump touted the federal
government's relief effort as far as
porto rico is concerned that's been
going as you know really well it's been
total devastation we have over 10,000
people in Puerto Rico right now we're
getting truck drivers because the people
from Puerto Rico the drivers just aren't
there they're looking for their homes
they have a lot of other problems
likewise with the police force but I
think it's going really well considering
David Begg know is in San Juan the
capital where some are telling a
different story David good morning
good morning the Puerto Rican governor
and federal officials have said the same
thing since the very beginning we're
doing the best we can given the
situation and given the resources that
we have
but then the acting head of the
Department of Homeland Security took it
a step further this week and she said
the aid response here on the island of
Puerto Rico was a good news story and
that sent the mayor of San Juan over the
edge Mayday we are in trouble
San Juan mayor you lean crews blasted
the federal government's response in the
aftermath of Hurricane Maria we are
dying here and I cannot fathom the
thought that the greatest nation in the
world cannot figure out logistics for a
small island of a hundred miles by 35
miles nearly everyone on the island of
3.4 million people is still without
power and almost half have no running
water
we saw it firsthand when we traveled to
aqua dia on the western tip of Puerto
Rico we need help we don't need money
just we need help
locals brought gallon jugs to fill with
water from a truck other people waited
in line for hours to get four bottles of
water and a few snacks and for some it
may have to last a few days people in
Aguadilla are using Clorox containers to
fill up for water what happened to your
house this is Jimmy my roof blew off and
I loved that almost day
do you got food I'm not just a little
bit just a little but you're running out
and I'm running out with many roads
still impassable the military is
delivering aid by helicopter on Friday
the acting Homeland Security Director
Elaine doof visited Puerto Rico and
promised more help but back in San Juan
the mayor was pressuring the White House
to speed it up so I am asking the
President of the United States to make
sure somebody is in charge that is up to
the task of saving lives the official
death count given by the government is
16 but that number has been staying
around 16 for the last five days so the
governor's having a press conference
this morning and we plan to press him on
that because we have heard from local
officials in elsewhere in other places
around the island that the number is far
higher so Dana we will get more
information about that but let me also
say this ten days after the hurricane
people are still using social media to
beg for help on behalf of their
relatives who are here on this
we just hope people are listening to it
too David beg no continuing some great
reporting in San Juan Puerto Rico thank
you